but the s p is such a dominant party in
Scotland that you know you don't act you
can win elections
um without having to seek to persuade
anyone who isn't already an s p a
committed SNP supporter
um you don't actually have to reach
across political divides you don't have
to have a a big tent a big Scotland um
uh type approach you can just win an
election by appealing to the SMP Rank
and file and its core support but that
doesn't help you get to the 50 threshold
that one day you need for Independence
um and so the SMP is trapped in this
situation where it is relatively easy
for them to continue to dominate
Scottish politics with 40 of the vote 45
of the vote but getting that you know
those final few percentage points is
what they require in the longer term
becomes very much more difficult and
what works for the base the party
membership may not be what is required
for the general public
um that you need to appeal to